hi everyone i'll get started okay so
we're now i'm back for the second week
of
cs224n
um on natural language processing with
deep learning
okay so um for today's lecture what
we're going to be looking at is
all the
math details of doing neural net
learning first of all looking at
how we can work out by hand um gradients
for training neural networks and then
looking at how it's done more
algorithmically which is known as the
back propagation algorithm
and
correspondingly for you guys um well i
hope you remembered that you know one
minute ago was when assignment one was
due and everyone has handed that in if
by some chance you haven't handed it in
um
really should hand it in as soon as
possible best to preserve those late
days for the harder assignments so i
mean i actually forgot to mention we
actually did make one change um for this
year to make it a bit easier when
occasionally people join the class a
week late if you want to this year in
the grading um assignment one can be
discounted and we'll just use your other
four assignments but if you've been in
the class so far for that 98 percent of
people well since assignment one is the
easiest assignment again it's silly not
to do it and have it as part of your
grade
okay so
starting today we've put out assignment
two and assignment two is all about
making sure you really understand the
math of neural networks and then the
software that we use to do that math
so this is going to be a bit of a tough
week for some so for some people who are
great on all their math and backgrounds
um they'll feel like this is stuff they
know well nothing very difficult but i
know there are quite a few of you um who
this lecture and week is the biggest
struggle of the course
we really do want people to actually
have an understanding of what goes on in
your network learning rather than
viewing it as some kind of deep magic
and i hope that some of the material we
give today and that you read up on and
use in the assignment will really give
you
more of a sense of what these neural
networks are doing and how it is just
math that's applied in the systematic
large scale that works out the answers
and that this will be valuable and
giving you a deeper sense of what's
going on but if this material seems very
um scary and difficult
you can take some refuge in the fact
that there's fast light at the end of
the tunnel since this is really the only
lecture that's heavily going through the
math details of neural networks after
that we'll be kind of popping back up to
a higher level
and by and large after this week we'll
be making use of software to do a lot of
the complicated math for us
um but nevertheless i hope this is
valuable i'll go through everything
quickly today but
if this isn't stuff that you know
backwards i really do encourage you um
to you know work through it and get help
as you need it so do come along to our
office hours there are also a number of
pieces of tutorial material given in the
syllabus so there's both the lecture
notes there's some materials from cs231
um in the list of readings the very top
reading is uh some material put together
by kevin clark a couple of years ago and
actually that one's my favorite the
presentation there fairly closely
follows the presentation in this lecture
of going through matrix calculus so you
know personally i'd recommend starting
with that one but there are four
different ones you can choose from if
one of them seems more helpful to you
two other things on what's coming up um
actually for thursday's lecture
we make a big change and thursday's
lecture is probably the most linguistic
lecture of the whole class where we go
through the details of dependency
grammar and dependency parsing some
people find that tough as well but at
least it'll be tough in a different way
and then one other really good
opportunity is
this friday we have our second tutorial
at 10 a.m which is an introduction to
pie torch which is the deep learning
framework that we'll be using for the
rest of the class once we've gone
through these first two assignments
where you um do things by yourself um so
this is a great chance to get intro to
pytorch they'll be really useful for
later in the class
okay
um today's material is really all about
sort of the math of neural networks but
just to sort of introduce a setting
where we can work through this i'm going
to introduce a simple nlp task and a
simple form of classifier that we can
use for it so the task of named entity
recognition is a very common basic nlp
task and the goal of this is you're
looking through pieces of text and
you're wanting to label by labeling the
words which words belong to entity
categories like persons locations
products dates times etc so for this
piece of text last night paris hilton
wowed in the sequin gown samuel quinn
was arrested in the hilton hotel in
paris in april 1989 the the some words
are being labeled as named entities as
shown um these two sentences don't
actually belong together in the same
article but i chose those two sentences
to illustrate the basic point that it's
not that you can just do this task by
using a dictionary yes a dictionary is
helpful to know that paris can possibly
be a location but paris can also be a
person name so you have to use context
to get
named entity recognition right
okay well how might we do that
with the neural network
there are much more advanced ways of
doing this but a simple yet already
pretty good way of doing um
named entity recognition within a simple
neural net is to say
well what we're going to do is use the
word vectors that we've learned about
and we're going to build up a context
window of word vectors
and then we're going to put those
through a neural network layer
and then feed it through a softmax
classifier of the kind that we um
sorry i said that wrong and then we're
going to feed it through a logistic
classifier of the kind that we saw when
looking at negative sampling which is
going to say for a particular entity
type such as location
is it high probability
location or is it not a high probability
location so for a sentence like the
museums in paris are amazing to see
what we're going to do is for each word
say we're doing the word paris we're
going to form a window around it say a
plus or minus two word window and so for
those five words we're going to get word
vectors for them from the kind of
word debacle glove word vectors we've
learned and we're going to make a long
vector out of the concatenation of those
five word vectors so the word of
interest is in the middle and then we're
going to feed
this
vector to a classifier which is at the
end going to have a probability of the
word being a location and then we could
have another classifier that says the
probability of the word being a person
name and so once we've done that we're
then going to run it at the next
position so we then say well is the word
r a location and we'd feed a window of
five words as then in paris are amazing
too and put it through the same kind of
classifier
and so this is the classifier that we'll
use so it's input will be this
word window so if we have d dimensional
word vectors this will be a 5d vector
and then we're going to put it through a
layer of a neural network so the layer
of the neural network is going to
multiply this vector by a matrix
add on a bias vector
and then put that through a
non-linearity
such as the
soft max transformation that we've seen
before
and that will give us a hidden vector
which might be of a smaller
dimensionality such as this one here
and so then with that hidden
vector we're then going to take the dot
product of it with an extra
vector here here's u so we take u dot
product h and so when we do that we're
getting out a single number and that
number can be any real number
and so then finally we're going to put
that number through
a logistic transform of the same kind
that we saw when doing negative sampling
the logistic transform will take any
real number and it will transform it
into a probability that that word is a
location so its output is the predicted
probability of the word belonging to a
particular class and so this could be
our location classifier which could
classify each word in a window as to
what the probability is that it's a
location word
and so this little neural network here
is
the neural network i'm going to use
today when going through some of the
math
but actually i'm going to make it even
easier on myself i'm going to throw away
the
logistic function at the top and i'm
really just going to work through the
math of the bottom three quarters of
this if you look at kevin clark's
handout that i just mentioned he
includes when he works through it also
working through the logistic
function and we also saw working through
a softnext in the first lecture when i
was working through some of the word
today model
okay
um
so the overall question we want to be
able to answer is so here's our
stochastic gradient descent equation
that we have existing um parameters of
our model
and we want to update them based on
our current loss which is at the j of
theta so
for getting our um loss here that the
true answer as to whether a word is a
location or not will be either you know
one if it is a location or zero if it
isn't our logistic classifier will
return some number like um 0.9 and we'll
use the distance away from what it
should have been squared as our loss
um so we work out a loss and then we're
moving a little distance in the negative
of the gradient which will be in
changing our parameter estimates in such
a way that they reduce the loss
and so this is already being written in
terms of a whole vector of parameters
which is being updated as to a new
vector of parameters but you can also
think about it that for each individual
parameter theta j
that we're working out the partial
derivative of the loss with respect to
that
parameter and then we're moving a little
bit in the negative direction of that um
that's going to give us a new value for
parameter theta j
and we're going to update all of the
parameters of our model as we learn
i mean in particular in contrast to what
commonly happens in statistics we also
we
update not only
the sort of parameters of our model that
are sort of weights in the classifier
but we also will update our data
representation so we'll also be changing
our word vectors as we learn
okay so to build neural nets i.e to
train neural nets based on data what we
need is to be able to compute this
gradient of the parameters so that we
can then iteratively update the weights
of the model and efficiently train a
model that has good weights i.e that has
high accuracy
and so how can we do that um well
what i'm going to talk about today is
first of all um how you can do it by
hand
and so for doing it by hand this is
basically a review of matrix calculus
and that'll take quite a bit of the
lecture
and then
after um we've talked about that for a
while i'll then shift gears and
introduce the back propagation algorithm
which is the central technology
for neural networks and that technology
is essentially
the efficient application of calculus on
a large scale as we'll come to talking
about soon
so for computing gradients by hand
what we're doing is matrix calculus so
we're working with vectors and matrices
and working out gradients and this can
seem like pretty scary stuff
and well to the extent that you're kind
of scared and don't know what's going on
one choice is to work out a
non-vectorized gradient by just working
out what the partial derivative is for
one parameter at a time and i showed a
little example of that in the first
lecture
but it's
much much faster and more useful to
actually be able to work
with
vectorized gradients
and in some sense if you're not very
confident this is kind of almost a leap
of faith but it really is the case that
multi-variable calculus is just like
single variable calculus except you're
using vectors and matrices so providing
you remember some basics of single
variable calculus you really should be
able to do this stuff and get it to work
out
lots of other
sources i've mentioned the notes
you can also look at the
textbook for math 51 or which also has
quite a lot of material on this
i know some of you have bad memories of
math 51. um okay so let's go through
this and see how it works from ramping
up from the beginning so the beginning
of calculus is you know we have a
function with one input and one output f
of x equals x cubed and so then its
gradient is its slope right so that's
its derivative so um its derivative is
three 3x squared and the way to think
about this is how much will the output
change if we change the input a little
bit right so what we're wanting to do in
our neural net models is change what
they output so that they do a better job
of predicting the correct answers when
we're doing supervised learning and so
what we want to know is if we
fiddle different parameters of the model
how much of an effect will that have on
the output because then we can choose
how to fiddle them in the right way to
move things down right so you know when
we're saying that the derivative here is
3x squared well
what we're saying is that if you're at x
equals one if you fiddle the input a
little bit the output will change three
times as much three times one squared
and it does so if i say what's the value
at 1.01 it's about 1.03
it's changed three times as much and
that's its slope
but at x equals four um the
derivative is
16 times 348 so if we fiddle the input a
little it'll change 48 times as much and
that's roughly what happens 4.01 cubed
is is
64.48 now of course you know this is
just sort of i'm showing it for a small
fiddle but you know that's an
approximation to the actual truth
okay so um then we sort of ramp up to
the more complex cases which are more
reflective of what we do with neural
networks so um if we have a function
with one output and n inputs then we
have a gradient so a gradient is a
vector of partial derivatives with
respect to each input so we've got n
inputs x1 to xn and we're working out
the partial derivative of f with respect
to x1 the partial derivative of f with
expected respect to x2 etc and we then
get a vector of partial derivatives
where each element of this vector is
just like a simple derivative with
respect to one variable
okay so from that point we just keep on
ramping up for what we do with neural
networks so commonly when we have
something like a layer in a neural
network we'll have a function within
inputs they'll be like our word vectors
then we
do something like multiply by a matrix
and then we'll have m outputs so we have
a function now which is taking n inputs
and is producing m outputs
so at this point um what we're
calculating for the gradient is what's
called a jacobian matrix so for m inputs
and n outputs the jacobian is an m by n
matrix of partial of every combination
of partial derivatives so um i
function f splits up into these
different sub functions f1 through m
fm which generate each of the m outputs
and so then we're taking the partial
derivative of f1 with respect to x1
through the partial derivative of f1
with respect to xn
then heading down you know we make it up
to the partial derivative of fm with
respect to x1 etc so we have every
possible partial derivative of an output
variable with respect to one of the
input variables
okay
so in simple calculus
when you have a composition of one
variable functions so that if you have
um
y equals x squared and then z equals
three y
um that's then z is
a composition of two functions
of well you're composing two functions
to get z as a function of x then you can
work out the derivative of z with
respect to x and the way you do that is
with the chain rule and so in the chain
rule you multiply derivatives so
dz dx equals dz dy times dydx
so
dzy
is just 3
and dydx is 2x so we get 3 times 2x so
that overall um
the
derivative here is 6x and
since if we multiply this together we're
really saying that z equals 3x squared
um you should trivially be able to see
again aha
its derivative is 6x so that works okay
um so once we move into vectors and
matrices and jacobians um it's actually
the same game so when we're working with
those we can compose functions and work
out their derivatives by simply
multiplying jacobians so if we have
start with an input x and then put it
through
the simplest form of neural network
layer and say that z
equals wx plus b so we multiply that the
x vector by matrix w and then add on a
bias vector b
and then typically we'd put things
through a non-linearity
f so f could be a sigmoid function we'll
then say h equals f of z so this is the
composition of two functions in terms of
um vectors and matrices
so we can use jacobians and we can say
the partial of h with respect to x is
going to be the product um of the
partial of h with respect to z and the
partial of zero with respect to x
and this all does work out so let's
start going through
some examples of how these things work
slightly more concretely
first
just particular jacobians and then
composing them together so one case we
look at is the
non-linearities that we put a vector
through so this is something like
putting a vector through the sigmoid
function f
um and so if
we have an intermediate vector z and we
turn into vector h by putting it through
us a logistic function we can say
what is
dhdz um
well
for this
um
formally this is a function that has n
inputs and n outputs so at the end of
the day
we're computing an n by n jacobian and
so
what that's meaning is the elements of
this n by n jacobian are going to take
the partial derivative of each
output with respect to each input
and well what is that going to be in
this case
well in this case because we're actually
just computing element wise
a transformation such as a logistic
transform of each element zi
like the second equation here
if
i equals j we've got something to
compute whereas if i doesn't equal j
um there's just
the input has no influence on the output
and so the derivative of zero so if i
doesn't equal j we're going to get a
zero and if i does equal j what then
we're going to get the regular one
variable
derivative of the logistic function
which if i remember correctly um
you were asked to
compute
now i can't remember it's assigned one
or assignment two but one of the two
asks you to compute it um so our
jacobian for this case looks like this
we have a diagonal matrix with the um
the
derivatives of each element along the
diagonal and everything else is zero
okay so let's look at a couple of other
jacobians um so if we
are asking if we've got this w x plus b
basic neural network layer and we're
asking um for the gradient with respect
to x
then what we're going to have coming out
is that that's actually going to be the
matrix w so this is where
what i hope you can do
is
look at the notes at home and work
through
[Music]
this exactly and see that this is
actually the right answer but this is
the way in which if you just have faith
and think this is a just like single
variable calculus
except i've now got vectors and matrices
the answer you get is actually what you
expected to get because this is just
like um
the derivative of ax plus b with respect
to x where it's a
so similarly if we take the partial
derivative with respect to b
of w x plus b we get out the identity
matrix
okay then one other jacobian that we
mentioned um while in the first lecture
while working through word to vac is if
you have the dot product of two
um
vectors
i that's a number that what you get
coming out of that it so that
the partial derivative
of u t h with respect to u
is h transpose
and at this point there's some fine
print that i'm going to come back to
in a
minute
so this is the correct jacobian right
because in this case um we have
the dimension
of
h inputs and we have one output
and so we want to have
a row vector
um
but there's a little bit more to say on
that that i'll come back to in about 20
slides um but this is the correct
jacobian
okay so
if you are not familiar with these kind
of jacobians do please
look at some of the
notes that are available and try and
compute these in more detail element
wise and convince yourself that they
really are right but i'm going to assume
these now and show you what happens when
we actually then work out gradients for
at least a mini little neural net
okay
so here is most of this um neural net i
mean as i commented um
that you know really we'd be working out
the partial derivative of the loss j
with respect to these variables but for
the example i'm doing here i just i've
locked that off to keep it a little
simpler and more manageable for the
lecture and so we're going to just work
out the partial derivative of the score
s which is a real number with respect to
the different parameters of this model
where the parameters of this model are
going to be the w and the b
and the
u
and also
the input because we can update the
weight vectors of
the
the word vectors of different words
based on
tuning them to better predict um the
classification outputs that we desire
so let's start off with a fairly easy
one where we want to update um the bias
vector b
to have our system um classify better so
to be able to do that what we want to
work out is the partial derivatives of s
with respect to b
so we know how to put that into our
stochastic gradient
update
for the b parameters
okay so how do we go about doing these
things so the first step is we want to
sort of break things up
into different functions of minimal
complexity that compose together so in
particular this neural net layer h
equals f of w x plus b it's still a
little bit complex so let's decompose
that one further step so um we have the
input x
we then
calculate
the linear transformation z equals wx
plus b
and then
um we put things through
the sort of element-wise non-linearity
h equals f of z
and then we do the dot product with u
and you know it's useful for working
these things out
you know split into pieces like this
have straight what your different
variables are and to know what the
dimensionality of each of these
variables is it's well worth just
writing out the dimensionality of every
variable and making sure that the
answers that you're computing are of the
right dimensionality
so at this point though what we can see
is that calculating s
is the product of
three
sorry is the composition of three
functions around x so for working out
the partials of s with respect to b
um it's the composition of the three
functions shown on the left and so
therefore
the gradient of s with respect to b
we're going to take um the
product of
these
three partial derivatives
okay so how do what do we that so
um so you know we've got the s equals u
t h so that's the sort of the top um
corresponding partial derivative partial
derivative of h with respect to z
partial derivative of z with respect um
to b which is the first one that we're
working out
okay so we want to work this out and if
we're lucky we remember those jacobians
i showed previously about the jacobian
for a vector dot product
the jacobian
for the non-linearity and the jacobian
for the simple linear transformation and
so we can use those so
for
the partials of s
with respect to h
well that's going to be ut using the
first one
the partials of h with respect to z okay
so that's the non-linearity and so
that's going to be
the matrix that's the diagonal matrix
with the element wise derivative f prime
of z and 0 elsewhere and
then for the w x plus b
when we're taking the partials with
respect to b
that's just the identity matrix
so we can simplify that down a little
the identity matrix disappears
and
since
u t
is a vector and this is a diagonal
matrix we can rewrite this as ut
hadamard product of f prime of z i think
this is the first time i've used this
little circle for hadamard product but
it it's something that you'll
see quite a bit in your network work
since it's often used so when
we have two vectors
ut and this vector here sometimes you
want to do an
element-wise product so the output of
this will be a vector where you've taken
the first element of each and multiplied
then the second element of each and
multiplied them etc downwards and so
that's called the hadamard product and
it's what we're calculating as
to calculate a vector
which is the gradient of
s with respect to b
okay so
that's good so we now have a gradient of
s with respect to b and we could use
that in our stochastic gradient but we
don't stop there
we also want to work out the gradient
with respect to others of our parameters
so we might want to next go on
and work out the gradient of s with
respect to w
well we can use the chain rule just like
we did before right so we've got the
same product of functions and everything
is going to be the same apart from me
now taking
um the derivatives with respect to w
rather than b
um so it's now going to be um the
partial of s with respect to h h with
respect to z and z with respect to w
and the important thing to notice here
and this leads into what we do with the
backpropagation algorithm is wait a
minute
this is very similar to what we've
already done so when we're working out
the gradients of s with respect to b
the first two terms were exactly the
same it's only the last one that differs
so
to be able to build um or to train
neural networks efficiently
this is what happens all the time and
it's absolutely essential that we use an
algorithm that avoids repeated
computation
and so
the idea we're going to develop is when
we have this equation stack that there's
sort of stuff that's above
um where we compute z
and we're going to be sort of that'll be
the same each time and we want to
compute something from that that we can
then sort of feed downwards when working
out the gradients with respect to w x or
b
and so
we do that by defining delta which is
delta is the partials composed that are
above
the linear transform and that's referred
to as the local error signal it's what's
being passed in from above
to the linear transform and we've
already computed
the gradient of that in the preceding
slides and so the final form of the
partial of s with respect to b will be
um
delta
times the remaining part and well we've
seen that you know for
um partial of s with respect to b
um the partial of z with respect to b is
just the identity so the end result was
delta but in this time we're then going
to have to work out the partial of z
with respect to w and multiply that by
delta so that's the part that we still
haven't yet done
so
um
and this is where things get
in some sense a little bit hairier
and so there's something that's
important to explain um so
you know what should we have for the
jacobian of
um dsdw
well
that's
a function
that has one output the output is just a
score a real number and then it has n by
m inputs so
the jacobian is
um a 1 by n
by m matrix i
a very long row vector
but
um that's correct math but it turns out
that that's kind of bad for our neural
networks
because remember what we want to do with
our neural networks is do
stochastic gradient descent and we want
to say theta nu equals theta old
minus
a small multiplier times
the gradient and well
actually
the w matrix
is an n by m matrix
and so we couldn't actually do the
subtraction if this gradient we
calculate is just a huge row vector we'd
like to have it as the same shape
as the w matrix
in neural network land when we do this
um we depart from pure math at this
point and we use what we call the shape
convention
so what we're going to say is um and
you're meant to use this for answers in
the assignment that the shape of the
gradient we're always going to make to
be the shape of the parameters
and so therefore
um
the sdw we're also going to represent as
an n by m matrix just like w
and we're going to reshape
the jacobian to place it into this
matrix shape
okay so if we want to place it into this
what
do we what are we going to want to get
for the sdw
well
we know that it's going to involve
delta our local error signal
and
then we have to work out something for
dz dw
um well since c equals wx plus b
you'd kind of expect that the answer
should be x
um
and that's right so the answer um to
dsdw
is um going to be
delta transpose times x transpose and so
the form that we're getting for this
derivative is going to be the product of
the local error signal at
that's in comes from above
versus what we calculate from the local
input x
so that shouldn't yet be obvious why
that is true so let me just go through
in a bit more detail why that's true
so when we want to
work out um
d
s d w right it's sort of delta times dz
dw where um what that's computing for z
is wx plus b
so let's just consider for a moment what
the derivative is with respect to a
single weight w i j
so w i j might be w 2 3 that's shown in
my little neural network here
and so the first thing to notice
is that w i j
only contributes to zi
so
it's going into
z2 which then computes h2 and it has no
effect whatsoever on h1
okay so when we're working out um dzi dw
i j
it's going to be
d w i
x that sort of row
that row of the matrix plus bi
which means um that for
we've got a kind of a sum of w i k times
x k
and then for this sum this is like one
variable calculus that when we're taking
the derivative of this with respect to w
i j
every term and this sum is going to be
zero
the derivative is going to be zero
except for the one that involves w i j
and then the derivative of that is just
like
a x with respect to a it's going to be x
so you get x j out as the answer
and so the end result of that is that
when we're working out what we want is
the answer is that we're going to um
get
that these
columns where x1 is all that's left x2
is all that's left through xm is all
that's left and then that's multiplied
by the vectors of the local error signal
from above and what we want to compute
is this outer product matrix where we're
getting the different combinations of
the delta
and the x and so we can get the n by m
matrix that we'd like to have by our
shape convention by taking
delta transpose which is n by 1 times x
transpose which is then 1 by m and then
we get this outer product matrix um so
like that's the kind of a hacky argument
that i've made it's certainly a way of
doing things that the dimensions work
out and it sort of makes sense um
there's a more detailed run through this
that appears in lecture notes um and i
encourage you to sort of also look at
the more matty version of that
here's a little bit more information
about um the shape convention so
well first of all one um
more
example of this so when you're working
out
the sdb
that
that comes out as a it's jacobian is a
row vector um but similarly you know
according to shape convention we want
our gradient to be the same shape as b
and b is a column vector
so that's sort of again they're
different shapes and you have to
transpose one to get the other
and so effectively what we have is a
disagreement between the jacobian form
so the jacobian form makes sense for
you know calculus and math because if
you want to have it like i claimed that
matrix calculus is just like single
variable calculus apart from using
vectors and matrices you can just
multiply together the partials that only
works out if you're using jacobians
but on the other hand if you want to do
stochastic gradient descent
and
be able to sort of subtract off a piece
of the gradient that only works
if you have the same shape matrix
for the
gradient as you do for the original
matrix
and so
this is a bit confusing but that's just
the reality there are both of these um
two things so the jacobian form is
useful in doing the um calculus
but for the answers in the assignment we
want the answers um to be presented
using the shape convention so that
the gradient is shown in the same shape
as
the parameters and therefore you'll be
able to it's the right shape for doing a
gradient update by just subtracting a
small amount of the gradient
so for working through things
there are then basically two choices
one choice is to work through all the
math using jacobians and then right at
the end um to reshape following the
shape convention to give the answer so
that's what i did when i worked out dsdb
we
worked through it
using
jacobians we got an answer
but it turned out to be a row vector and
so well then we have to transpose it at
the end to get it into the right shape
for the shape convention
um
the alternative is
um to always follow the shape convention
um and that's kind of what i did when i
was then working out dsdw i didn't fully
use jacobians i said oh well when we
work out
whatever was dz dw let's work out what
shape we want it to be and what to fill
in the cells with
and if you're sort of
trying to do it um immediately with the
shape convention
it's a little bit more
hacky
in a way since you know you have to look
at the dimensions for what you want and
figure out when to transpose or to
reshape the matrix to be at the right
shape but the kind of informal reasoning
that i gave
is what you do and what works and you
know one way of
and there are sort of hints that you can
use right that you know that your
gradient should always be the same shape
as your parameters and you know that the
error message coming in
will always have the same dimensionality
as that hidden layer and you can sort of
work it out always following the shape
convention
okay
um
so that
is
hey
doing this is all
matrix calculus
so after pausing for breath
for a second
the
rest of the lecture
is then okay
let's look at how our software
trains neural networks using what's
referred to as the back propagation the
back propagation algorithm
um
so
the short answer is
you know
basically we've already done it the rest
of the lecture is easy um so you know
essentially
i've just shown you what the back
propagation algorithm does
um so
the back propagation algorithm
is
judiciously
taking
and
propagating
derivatives
using the matrix chain rule
the rest of the back propagation
algorithm is to say
okay when we have these neural networks
we have a lot of shared structure and
shared derivatives so what we want to do
is maximally efficiently reuse
derivatives
of higher layers when we're computing
derivatives for lower layers so that we
minimize computation and i already
pointed that out in the first half but
we want to systematically exploit that
and so the way we do that
in our computational systems is they
construct computation graphs
um so this maybe looks a little bit like
what you saw in a compiler's class if
you did one right that you're creating
i'm i call it here computation graph but
it's really a tree right so you're
creating here this tree of computations
in this case but in more general case
it's some kind of directed graph of
computations
which has
source nodes which are inputs either
inputs like x or input parameters like w
and b
and it's interior nodes are operations
and so then once we've constructed a
graph and so this graph corresponds to
exactly the example i did before right
this was our little neural net that's in
the top right and here's the
corresponding computation graph of
computing w x plus b
put it through
the sigmoid non-linearity f
multiply the resulting dot product of
the resulting vector with u gives us our
output score s
um
okay so
what we do to compute this is we pass
along the edges the results of
operations so this is w x then z then h
and then our output is s
and so the first thing we want to be
able to do to compute with neural
networks is to be able to compute for
different inputs what the output is and
so that's referred to as forward
propagation and so we simply
run
this
expression
much like
you'd standardly do in a compiler to
compute the value of s and that's the
forward propagation phase but the
essential additional element of neural
networks is that we then also want to be
able to send back gradients which will
tell us how to update the parameters of
the model and so it's this ability um to
send back gradients which gives us the
ability for these models to learn once
we have a loss function at the end we
can work out how to change the
parameters of the model so that they
more accurately
produce the desired output i they
minimize the loss and so it's doing that
part that then is called back
propagation
so we then once we forward propagated a
value with our current parameters
we then um
head backwards reversing the direction
of the arrows and pass along gradients
down to the different parameters like b
and w and u that we can use to change
using stochastic gradient to send what
the value of b is of what the value of w
is so we start off with dsds which is
just one
and then we
run our back propagation and we're using
the sort of same kind of composition
of jacobian so we have the sdh here and
the sdz and we progressively
pass back those gradients
so we just need to work out how to
efficiently and cleanly do this in a
computational system and so let's sort
of work through again a few of these
cases so the general situation is
um we have
a particular node so a node is where
some kind of
operation like multiplication or
a non-linearity happens and so the
simplest case is that we've got one
output and one input so we'll do that
first so that's like h equals f of z
so
what we have
is an upstream gradient
um
dsdh and what we want to do
is compute the downstream gradient of
dsdz
and the way we're going to do that is
say well for this function f
it's a function
it's got a derivative a gradient so what
we want to do is work out that local
gradient dhdz
and then
that gives us everything that we need to
work out the sdz because that's
precisely we're going to use the chain
rule we're going to say the dsdz equals
the product of the sdh times the hdz
where this is again using jacobians
okay so the general principle that we're
going to use is the downstream gradient
equals the upstream gradient times the
local gradient
okay sometimes it gets a little bit more
complicated so we might have multiple
inputs to a function so this is
the matrix vector multiply so z equals
wx okay when there are multiple inputs
we still have an upstream gradient
dsdz
but what we're going to do is work out a
local gradient with respect to each
input so we have dz dw and
dzdx and so then at that point it's
exactly the same
for each piece of it we're going to work
out the downstream gradients the sdw and
the sdx by using the chain rule with
respect to the
particular local gradient
so um let's go through an example of
this i mean this is kind of a silly
example it's not really an example that
looks like a typical neural net but it's
sort of a simple example where we can
show some of the components of what we
do so what we're going to do is want to
calculate
f of x y z
which is being calculated as x plus y
times the max of y and z
um and we've got you know particular
values that we're starting off with x
equals one y equals two and z equals
zero so these are the current values of
our parameters
and so we can say okay
well we want to
build an expression tree for that here's
our expression tree
we're taking x
plus y we're taking the max of y and z
and then we're multiplying them
and so our forward propagation
phase is just to run this so we take the
values of our parameters and we simply
start to compute with them right so we
have one two two zero um and we add them
as three the max is two we multiply them
and that gives us six
okay so then at that point
we then want to go and work out um
how to
do things um for back propagation and
how these back propagation steps work
and so the first part of that is sort of
working out what our local gradients are
going to be
um so
um so this is a here and this is x and y
so d a d x since a equals x plus y is
just going to be one and d a d y is also
going to be one
um
then
um for
b equals the max of y z
um so this is this max node so the local
gradients for that is um it's going to
depend on y b whether y is greater than
z so d b d y
is going to be
one if and only if y is greater than z
which it is at our particular point here
so that's one and db dz
is going to be one only if
z is greater than y so for our
particular values here
that one is going to be
zero
um and then finally here we're
calculating the product f equals a b
um so
for that um
we're going to
um
wait
sorry that slides along perfect okay so
for the product um the derivative of f
with respect to a is equal to b which is
two and the derivative of f with respect
to b is a equals three so that gives us
all of the local gradients
at each node and so then to run
backpropagation
we start with dfdf which is just one
and then we're going to
work out
the downstream equals the upstream times
the local
okay so the local
so when you have a product like this um
note that sort of the gradients flip
so we take upstream
times the local which is 2
oops
so the
downstream is 2
on this side
dfdb is three
so we're taking upstream times local
that gives us three
um and so that gives us back propagates
values to um the plus and max nodes and
so then we continue along
so for the max node um
the local gradient dbdy equals one so
we're going to take upstream is three so
we tend to take three times one
and that gives us three
d b d z is zero because of the fact that
z's value is not the max um so we're
taking three times zero and saying the
gradient there is zero so finally doing
the plus node um the local gradients for
both x and y there are one so we're just
getting two times one in both cases and
we're saying that the gradients there
are two
okay and so again at the end of the day
um the interpretation here is that this
is giving is this information as to if
we wiggle the values of x y and z how
much of a difference does it make to the
output what is the slope the gradient
with respect to the variable so what
we've seen is that since
z
isn't the max of y and z
if i change the value of z a little like
if i make z 0.1 or minus 0.1 it makes no
difference at all to what i compute as
the output so therefore the gradient
there is zero
if i change the value
of x a little
then that is going to have an effect and
it's going to affect the output by
twice as much as the amount i change it
oops
right so and that's because um the dfdz
equals two
um
so
interestingly um
so i mean we can basically work that out
so if we imagine um
making sort of x 2.1 well then what we'd
calculate the max is to
[Music]
oh sorry sorry if we make x 1.1
we then get the max here is 2
and we get 1.1 plus 2 as 3.1 so we get
3.1 times
2 so that'd be about 6.2
so changing x by 0.1
has added 0.2 to the value of f
um conversely for the value of y we find
that the df d y equals 5 so
what we do when we've got two things
coming out here as i'll go through again
in a moment is we're summing the
gradients so again three plus two equals
five and empirically that's what happens
so if we consider fiddling the value of
y a little let's say we make it
a value of 2.1 then the prediction is
they'll have
five times as bigger an effect on the
output value we compute and well what do
we compute so we
compute 1 plus 2.1 so that's 3.1 and we
compute the max of um
2.1 and 0 as 2.1 so we'll take the
product of 2.1 and 3.1 and i calculate
that in advance since i can't really do
this arithmetic in my head and the
product of those two is 6.51
so it has gone up about by
0.5 so we've multiplied my fiddly at by
0.1 by
five times to work out the magnitude of
the effect of the output
okay
so for this stuff
you know before
i did the case
of
you know when we had one oops one in and
one out
here and
multiple ends and one out here
the case that i hadn't actually dealt
with
is the case of when you have multiple
outward branches but that then turned up
in the computation of y
so once you have multiple outward
branches what you're doing is your
summing
so that when you want to work out
the
dfdy
you've got a local
gradient you've got two upstream
gradients
and you're working it out with respect
to each of them
as in the chain rule and then you're
summing them together to work out the
impact at the end
right so we also saw some of the other
node intuitions which it's useful to
have um doing this
so when you have an addition
um that distributes the upstream
gradient to each of the things below it
when you have max it's like a routing
node so when you have max you have the
upstream gradient and it goes to one of
the branches below it and the rest of
them get no gradient
um when you then have a multiplication
it has this effect of switching the
gradient so if you're taking
three by two
um the gradient on the two side is three
and on the three side is two and if you
think about in terms of how much effect
you get from when you're doing this sort
of wiggling that totally makes sense
right because if you're multiplying
another number by three then
any change here is going to be
multiplied by 3 and vice versa
okay so
that so this is the kind of computation
graph that we want to use
to work out
derivatives in an automated
computational fashion um which is the
basis of the back propagation algorithm
but at that point that you know this is
what we're doing but there's still you
know one mistake that we can make it
would be wrong for us to sort of say
okay well first of all we want to work
out the sdb
so look we can start up here we can
propagate our upstream errors work out
local gradients
upstream error local gradient and keep
all the way down
and get
the
dsdb down here okay next we want to do
it
for dsdw let's just run it all over
again because if we did that we'd be
doing
repeated computation as i showed in the
first half that this term
is the same both times this term is the
same both times this term is the same
both times that only the bits at the end
differ
so what we want to do
is avoid duplicated computation and
compute all the gradients um
that we're going to need um successively
so that we only do them once and so that
was analogous when i introduced this
delta variable when we computed
gradients by hand so starting off here
from
d
um we starting off here with dsds is one
we then want to one time compute
gradient in the green here one time
compute the gradient in green here
that's all common work
then we're going to take
the local gradient um
for
dz db
and multiply that by the upstream
gradient to work out dsdb
and then we're going to take the same
upstream gradient and then um
work out the local gradient here
um
and then sort of propagate that down to
give us the sdw
so the end result is we want to sort of
systematically
work to
forward computation forward in the graph
and backward computation
back propagation backward in the graph
in a way that we do things
efficiently
so this is the general form of the
algorithm which works for an arbitrary
computation graph
so at the end of the day we've got a
single scalar output
z
and then we have inputs and parameters
which
compute
z
and so once we have this computation
graph and i added in this funky
extra arrow here to make it a more
general computation graph well we can
always say
that we can work out a starting point
something that doesn't depend on
anything so in this case both of these
bottom two nodes don't depend on
anything else so we can start with them
and we can start to compute forward we
can compute
values for all of these sort of second
row from the bottom nodes and then we're
able to compute
um
the third lens up so
we can have a topological sort of the
nodes based on the dependencies in this
directed graph
and we can compute the value of each
node given some subset of its
predecessors which it depends on and so
doing that is referred to as the forward
propagation phase and gives us a
computation of the scalar output z
using our current parameters and our
current inputs
and so then after that we run back
propagation so for back propagation we
initialize the output gradient
dz dz
as one and then we visit nodes in the
reverse order of the topological sort
and we compute the gradients downward
and so our recipe is that for each node
as we head down we're going to
compute the gradient of the node with
respect to its successes and the things
that it feeds into
and how we compute that gradient is
using this chain rule that we've looked
at so this is sort of the generalized
form of the chain rule where we have
multiple outputs and so we're summing
over the different outputs and then for
each output we're computing the product
of the upstream gradient and the local
gradient
with respect to that node and so we head
downwards and we continue down
in the reverse topological sort order
and we work out um the gradient with
respect to each variable
in this graph
and so it hopefully looks um kind of
intuitive
looking at this picture
that
if you think of it like this the big oak
complexity of forward propagation and
backward propagation is the same right
in both cases you're doing a linear pass
through all of these nodes and
calculating values given predecessors
and then values given successes i mean
you have to do a little bit more work is
um for working out the gradients sort of
as shown by this chain rule but it's the
same big o complexity
so if somehow you're implementing stuff
for yourself rather than relying on the
software and you're calculating the
gradiences of a different order of
complexity of forward propagation it
means that you're doing something wrong
you're doing repeated work that you
shouldn't have to do
okay so this algorithm works
for a completely arbitrary
computation graph any directed acyclic
graph
you can apply this algorithm
in general what we find is that we build
neural networks that have a regular
layer structure so we have things like a
vector of inputs and then that's
multiplied by a matrix it's transformed
into another vector which
might be multiplied by another matrix or
summed with another matrix or something
right so once we're using that kind of
regular layer structure we can then
parallelize the computation by working
out the
gradients in terms of
jacobians of
vectors and matrices and do things in
parallel much more efficiently
okay
so doing this is then referred to as
automatic differentiation
and so essentially um
if you know the computation graph
you should be able to have your compute
clever computer system
work out um
what
the derivatives of everything is and
then apply
back propagation um to work out how to
update the parameters and learn
and there's actually a sort of an
interesting um
sort of
thing of how history has gone backwards
here
which i'll just
note um
so some of you might be
um familiar with symbolic um
computation packages so those are things
like mathematica so mathematica you can
give it a symbolic form of a computation
and then it can work out derivatives for
you
so it should be the case that if you
give a complete symbolic form of a
computation graph um
then it should be able to work out all
the derivatives for you and
you never have to work out a derivative
by hand whatsoever
and that was actually attempted in a
famous um deep learning library called
fianno which came out of joshua bendio's
group
at the university of montreal
that it had a compiler that did that
kind of symbolic manipulation
um
but
you know somehow that sort of proved um
a little bit too
too hard a road to follow i imagine it
actually might come back again in the
future and so
for
modern deep learning frameworks which
includes both tensorflow or pi torch
they do
90 percent
of um this computation of automatic
differentiation for you
but they don't actually symbolically
compute derivatives so for each
particular node or layer of your deep
learning system
somebody either you or the person who
wrote
that
layer has hand-written the local
derivatives but then everything from
that point on the sort of the taking
doing the chain rule of combining
upstream gradients with local gradients
to work out downstream gradients that's
then all being done automatically for
back propagation on the computation
graph
and so that what that means is for
a whole neural network you have a
computation graph and it's going to have
a forward
pass and a backward pass
and so for the forward pass you're
topologically sorting the nodes based on
their dependencies in the computation
graph and then for each
node you're running forward
the forward computation on that node and
then for backward propagation you are
reversing the topological sort of the
graph and then for each node in the
graph you're running the backward
propagation which is the little bit of
backdrop the chain rule at that node and
then the result of doing that is you
have gradients
for
your inputs and parameters
and so
this is the overall software runs this
for you and so what you
want to do is then actually
have stuff
for particular nodes or layers in the
graph so if i have a multiply
gate it's going to have a forward
algorithm which just computes that the
output is x times y in terms of the two
inputs and then i'm going to want to
compute to tell it also how to calculate
the local derivative so i want to say
what is the local derivative
so
dl dx and the ldy in terms of the
upstream gradient dldz
and so
i will then manually work out how to
calculate that and normally what i have
to do
is
i assume the forward pass is being run
first and i'm going to shove into some
local variables for my class the values
that were used in the forward
computation so as well as computing z
equals x times y
i'm going to sort of remember what x and
y were
so that then when i'm asked to compute
the backward pass i'm then going to have
implemented here um what we saw earlier
of
um that when it's x y you're going to
sort of swap the y and the x um to work
out
the local gradients and so then i'm
going to multiply those by the upstream
gradient and i'm going to return
i've just written it here as a sort of a
little list but really it's going to be
a numpy vector of the gradients
okay um
so that's um 98 of what i wanted to
cover um today just um a couple of quick
comments
um left so
um that can and should all be automated
sometimes you want to just check if
you're
computing the right gradients and so the
standard way of checking that you're
computing the right gradients is to
manually work out the gradient by doing
a numeric calculation of the gradient
and so
um you can do that so you can work out
what the derivative of x
of f with respect to x should be
by choosing some sort of small number
like 10 to the minus 4
adding it to x subtracting it from x and
then so the difference between these
numbers is 2h dividing it through by 2h
and you're simply working out the rise
over the run which is the slope of that
point with respect to x and that's an
approximation of the gradient of f with
respect to x
at that value of x so this is so simple
you can't make a mistake implementing
that and so therefore you can use this
to check um where your whether your
gradient values are correct or not um
this isn't something that you'd want to
use much um because not only is it
approximate but it's extremely slow
because to work this out you have to run
the forward computation for every
parameter of the model so if you have a
model with a million parameters you're
now doing a million times as much work
to run back prop as
as you would do if you're actually using
calculus so calculus is a good thing to
know but it can be really useful to
check that the right values are being
calculated in the old days when we hand
wrote everything
this was kind of the key unit test that
people used everywhere
these days most of the time you're
reusing layers that are built into pie
torch or some other deep learning
framework so it's much less
needed but sometimes you're implementing
your own layer and you really do want to
check that things are implemented
correctly
there's a fine point in the way this is
written if you saw this
in sort of high school calculus class
you would have seen rise over run of f
of x plus h minus f of x divided by h
it turns out that doing this two-sided
estimate like this is much much more
accurate than doing a one-sided estimate
and so you're really much encouraged to
use this approximation
okay so at that point um we've mastered
the core technology of neural nets um
backpropagation is recursively and hence
efficiently applying the chain rule
along the computation graph with this
sort of key step that downstream
gradient equals upstream abstract the
upstream gradient times local gradient
and so
for calculating with neural nets we do
the forward pass to work out values with
current parameters then run back
propagation
and work out the gradient
of the loss and currently computed loss
with respect to those parameters
now to some extent
um
you know with modern deep learning
frameworks you don't actually have to
know how to do any of this right it's
like it's the same as you don't have to
know how to implement a c compiler you
can just write c code and say gcc and
it'll compile it and it'll run um the
right stuff for you um and that's the
kind of functionality you get from the
pytorch framework so do come along to
the pie torch tutorial this friday and
get a sense about how easy it is to
write new networks um using a framework
like pytorch or tensorflow and you know
it's so easy that's why you know high
school students across the nation
are now doing their science projects
training deep learning systems because
you don't actually have to
understand very much debunk a few neural
network layers together and set it
computing
on some data
but you know we hope in this class that
you actually are also learning how these
things are implemented
um
so you have a deeper understanding of
than that and you know it turns out that
sometimes you need to have a deeper
understanding so back propagation
doesn't always work carefully perfectly
and so understanding what it's really
doing can be crucial to debugging things
and so we'll actually see an example of
that fairly soon when we start looking
at recurrent models and some of the
problems that they have which will
require us to think a bit more deeply
about what's happening in our gradient
computations
okay
that's it for today